it is shocking and brutal a 65 year old
asian woman walking to church
when she's attacked in broad daylight in
manhattan in new york
and no one comes to help as the man
stomped on her head
police say he made several anti-asian
comments it's the latest in a growing
series of attacks on asian americans
this assault considered a hate crime it
is absolutely terrifying because it
makes all of the asian american
community
you know say you know with resolve we're
not gonna leave our homes i mean
that's ultimately what is happening i am
i am angry i
am you know all the emotions it's never
the you know the frustration the anger
none of that has subsided because
the attacks haven't subsided new york
police also investigating another attack
on an asian man on a subway train in the
city
the man was beaten and choked to
unconsciousness
this video has now been viewed more than
two million times
the rise in attacks has brought out
people in support
on monday senate democratic leader chuck
schumer attended a vigil in new york
and at the weekend thousands took to the
streets at
anti-violence rallies and peace vigils
across the united states
i shouldn't have to be worried about my
mother being slashed
or pushed in the streets i shouldn't
have to be worried about getting
stabbed going on the train i'm a native
new yorker
and for the first time in my life i
carry a knife i carry around a hammer in
my bag just in case i'm going to get
attacked
police in new york have issued this
picture of the man they want to
interview
in connection with the attack on the 65
year old woman
she remains in hospital with serious
injuries
alan fisher al jazeera